welcome to Ed's on your Heights every
week it's all about me no camera well
boys looks like we're stuck together
forever like stink on a skunk or all of
us gonna be here forever
we're America see now but no road a key
I don't know here's 150 million Garrett
yeah we're the cool team remember to
nowadays
okay shake it off we'll get him next
year
there's nothing I can do I mean come on
who doesn't love these guys you know I'm
also a hot quarterback Hey
never give up kids well they won't eight
games in three years we're America's
Team okay uh let's earn it back
I'm Dakota Prescott and I swear I'm also
dangerous but I'm also pretty safe with
Jeff so I said what's a whistle I don't
need your fancy checker oh yeah we're
taking that back nope who's being robbed
now we deserve this thanks Berta
what about aa thank you
now respect we need the grounds Titans
maybe I
I'm footballs Tom Brady please buy my
special pliability room bus why would I
do that
can't you get hi I'm Julia Edelman and I
know Tom Brady please subscribe to this
channel